Hawkeye started out as a supervillain
back in 1964 but soon switched sides and
teamed up with the Avengers in 1965 and
he's been a key player in the Marvel
Universe ever since from his cameo
appearance in 2011 Thor through his
expanded roles in The Avengers movies
and Captain America Civil War Hawkeye is
a fixture of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe these days the studio was wise
enough to lock up and come at Jeremy ran
it into a long-term contract early on
and he's become a star in his own right
over the past few years so why won't
Marvel give Hawkeye a movie fatigue Rana
has been a cog in the marble machine for
a while now but he was famously and
happy with his role in The Avengers the
actor made it clear he felt his
character was shortchanged and
considering he spent most of the movie -
he brainwashed and working for Loki it's
hard to argue he told hero complex at
the end of the day 90% of the movie are
not the characterized find on the play
I'm literally in there for two minutes
and then all of a sudden thankfully he's
warmed up to his super role since then
during a reddit AMA while promoting
Avengers age of Ultron he said he would
be game if Marvel ever wanted to make a
superhero movie but he'll be six movies
in after the next two Avengers films he
may be game for now but it's hard enough
to wonder how long he'll be interested
in playing marbles man you can't miss
done the whole mind control thing not a
fan but let's assume Marvel starts to
look at hawkeye's comic-book history for
inspiration well they may not find much
short on stories Hawkeye has been around
the comic scene for decades but he
doesn't really have a lot of iconic
stories that would translate well to the
big screen the reason fans have been
begging for a Black Widow movie the
superspy is a mysterious backstory well
worth exploring the same goes for fellow
heroes like the Winter Soldier Hulk and
black panther but age of Ultron already
filled in a lot of the gaps in Hawkeye
story when he's not off being a hero he
lives a quiet life married to Linda
Cardellini and playing with his adorable
kids
Hawkeye is just a regular guy in the MCU
while that's part of his appeal it's
hard to make a hundred million dollar
blockbuster about an average guy
speaking of which the fraction factor
right so much fractions 2012 Hawkeye
series was one of the most acclaimed
comics marvel has published in year
but that doesn't mean it would be a good
fit on the big screen the comical
overheads because it pretty much ignored
the fact that Hawkeye is a superhero and
instead focus on his regular life in a
New York City apartment building
Hawkeye hung around with Kate Bishop a
young gay hero who also goes by the name
Hawkeye and faced off of a group of
Russian gangsters it was almost a
Seinfeld of comic books
well after ordering mr. Seinfeld mr.
Costanza debated on whether or not Iron
Man were some sort of undergarment
between his skin and his iron I still
say he's naked under there well that
makes a lot of Sahaj shot-up the series
was arguably Hawkeye's best outing in
comic books so fans might think it'd be
the right inspiration for a movie it's
even won a ton of awards and with a
crazy fun story but it didn't exactly
have the makings of a Hollywood
blockbuster though it would make one
heck of a good netflix TV series just
sayin
packed schedule you'll hear this one
pretty much anytime you talk about
Marvel movies they make a lot of them
and there are plenty more on the way the
studio has released more than a dozen
films with around half a dozen more
already in development you already have
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 Thor
Ragnarok Black Panther Captain Marvel
and the next two Avengers films on the
way and that's just naming a few but
simply there are lots of options on the
table and Hawkeye has already been in
his fair share of movies low power high
stakes no offense to all the archer
heroes in the Marvel and DC universes
but Hawkeye is basically a guy fighting
aliens and giant robots with a stick
enough strength ork I said it himself
okay look huge flying we're playing an
army of robot and have a bow and arrow
no no this makes sense but Ironman
doesn't make sense because he has cool
high-tech armor
Thor makes sense because he flies around
the universe splashing bad guys with a
magic hammer but shooting arrows it's
cool sure but it's not on the same level
nobody would know nobody
there's a reason DC decided to turn
green arrow into a TV series it seems
that skill set is just better suited for
adventures on a small screen team-up
Clint Barton was the heart and soul of
the Avengers and age of Ultron and
that's because he just works really well
on a team most of his best moments from
the MCU are when he teamed up with other
heroes and he's a character who work
that's when you have someone to play off
of he's had a lot of interesting story
arcs in the comics over the years but
most of them are tied to larger Avenger
stories he's died he's come back to life
he's even hung up his bow and arrow to
be a ninja for a while like he do but
all of those stories were connected to
the Avengers age of Ultron was pretty
much Hawkeye at his best and that's
because it gave fans just enough to
leave them wanting more as opposed to
two full hours of pure unfiltered
Hawkeye so what about Kate Marvel
doesn't seem to be afraid of trying out
new characters so why not give the other
arrow person a shot if Marvel really
wanted to get creative
it could bench Barton and introduce that
other Hawkeye Kate Bishop Kate was
introduced in 2005 in Marvel Comics
young Avengers comic series and took up
the name Hawkeye in 2006 over the past
decade she's become a close friends of
Barton and is arguably the better Archer
nowadays in the comics just kick you
around California to work as a
hard-boiled Private Eye so maybe she
should get a movie right but there's a
problem
outside of comic readers she isn't a
very well-known character at all
considering we are still waiting on
Miles Morales spider-man to get his own
live-action movie Kate seems like a long
shot - thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]